you know everyone gets to come home the
way they went or come back at all here
are your the yoga would have to have the
hidden Donna's for tom was indifferent
out the cavity with a rod gosh I'm so a
schmuck shocked was it starting as it he
loses but was a student of my father
to survive Mongolia's long cold winters
people burn coal and wood to heat their
homes a dome of smoke covers the
country's capital who lombardo smoke so
thick the city keeps the street lights
on even during the day air pollution in
Ulan Bator is seven times the amount
that is considered safe
nineteen-year-old Ziggy has grown up in
the smocks she's one of three young
people we talked to on the show who are
struggling with their health Ziggy has
trouble even carrying water home from
the well over the past years Ziggy has
repeatedly struggled with bronchitis the
bed air has left her lungs damaged but I
do and then again it's very hard for
lungs
here on the world to wooden you who
can't you see in Tudor and suspected
you'd who do ants a hard time teaching
the hatch illusion like most people here
say he lives on a traditional home
called a yurt more than half of the 1.3
million people in olin barter live in
your districts the air here smells like
smoke and I can feel my eyes sting I'm
walking through zouk beta the district
see he lives in its minus 17 degrees
Celsius that's quite mild for one of the
world's coldest cities but I am freezing
and very excited to warm up inside
cygnus yurt
in a heightened master as Jim's knee
sure saga nothing didn't you tell us
about a jalapeno it's good for lung and
held and okay Whitney drift I was saying
when you die started again come on you
and on pushing the wolf just handling
the milk jilted Marcel expand their
cheek he invites me to eat dumplings
with her and her younger brother Mooji
their parents left the city for years
ago to work in the countryside right
learn every month they sent back what
money they can in summer the kids go to
work with their parents they're outside
the city the air is much cleaner the
rest of the year though silly and her
brother stay in Ulan Bator to get an
education si tu t'en home altitude I was
talking to robert andrews the better
thing getting Thunder tom barrett and
which part was able to release it aside
rishta didn't have time to hoarder or
shake is what handle her yard where wish
tasha a hundred Hubert shoot indoors a
solid orange can punish them to
completely bro
this wall is a memorial to British
soldiers who lost their lives in
Afghanistan I've come here with David
the 27 year old survived both the
Afghanistan war and the conflict in Iraq
but some of his friends didn't know do
we know any of them yeah so this one was
my friend Brett who serve in Afghanistan
with us that's Lee and that's Josh how
old where Josh at the top was 18 not a
week away from his 19th birthday Lee was
about 24 25 and Brett was 18 19 other
time what was that like for you I never
thought you just you get told the news
and when you just go try and carry on
really they only have time to mourn the
deaths useful trying to get on with your
job have you had any fear of death and
this time got no choice really you got
to try and think you're going out there
with your friends at the same time so
therefore you're thinking at the same
but people need to keep a level head I
was level starts panicking and loafing
then you're just going to die faster so
you tried to do everything properly to
them to stay alive and don't think about
it David lost a leg in Afghanistan in
2009 he spent two years in a wheelchair
before getting an artificial limb those
were vehicles you were driving in
Afghanistan boss commanding it I would
be stood up top with the gun while my
drivers in the driver's seat and got
people in the back and you can have
people here but that's where I was stood
on top of the gun with all the radios
and stuff telling him where to go it
released after he got back from
Afghanistan David was different he had
outbursts of anger sometimes he couldn't
sleep for days and when he did he had
recurring nightmares mostly about the
mission that almost got him killed my
vehicle got hit by a bomb underneath
which launched me 45 foot into the air
shattering both of my legs hurt my back
and damaging my hair this is all I think
about like when I was having my
flashbacks it was just purely seeing me
get blown up again and again and again
and it was just like like I am now stood
watching it just driving past and watch
me get blown up that's the same vision I
had every night nestled between rolling
hills and rustic vineyards our next
story takes us to the village of ikana
I've come to Germany's wine country near
the border to France I'm here to meet 20
year old Alexander come see mama he's
one of 11,000 people in Germany who need
an organ transplant to survive it is
justice system 7 short eaber for now
this is what keeps Alex alive he has to
carry the device with him everywhere he
goes it regulates a pump implanted in
his heart then our course and inspire
the shipment so Emma and scar the losses
come down to alarm ok when done her
don't move the snow we dine sticker good
Mundy's is good a tiny Ferguson what is
her search donation cupful just fixed
derbyshire the gun said maybe a red one
front yard to start a fad in the scans
avisa so focus
these batteries power Alex's heart pump
it gets the electricity it needs from a
cable running through his abdomen
smarten on you sash tomorrow Fajada much
Angus mask few when you it's happened he
Nixon to IBM so out of a stall just I'm
GMU community neighbor dr shah oviya to
i spy squad vice versa ha and give ended
only one I've understood see one closer
to such naughty to the itself from the
Pumbaa Pumbaa lies don't rush i'm sure a
schmuck soaked was its dying was its
helo is it was was to meet up max hour
if anything happens to alex's support
system his organs won't get the oxygen
they need and his body will shut down
Alec still lives at home when he was
first put on the waiting list for a new
heart back in 2013 his family wasn't
prepared for what was in store ha binder
from his self a tank this kid question
an apple harvest and Bill a 11 on some
doctor does his best to fulfill our gear
and fish soup nomas art apart let us
clap some schmuck massive to town for
work
after his first pump nearly caused Alex
to have a stroke he now has to take
around a dozen pills a day to prevent
further complications to find out more
about ciggies Lyme disease we go to her
local clinic there are four doctors
working here in wintertime each one of
them treats at least 200 patients a day
the doctors say half of the patients are
sick because of air pollution whenever
te gets a cold her bronchitis comes back
that means the airways and her lungs get
inflamed the main triggers fatigue is
bronchitis a Mongolia's cold climate and
the smog test the doctor has already
prescribed to antibiotics many times but
they don't always work what the daughter
has dead but the health of just turn
buckles sig is trying her to stay
healthy so she doesn't damage your lungs
even more in all 29 condemn she'd
allegedly was not so sure sir Norton de
anda home but that has hot [ __ ] that
she was never that tomorrow or Hannah to
legitimate an adult a little startling
video dating her brigade pasado sussex
chiquis doctor tells her to keep warm to
avoid big groups of people and to get as
much fresh air as possible but fresh air
is hard to find in winter time
especially in poorer neighborhoods the
smoke is so heavy in Ulan Bator that
it's listed as one of the cities with
the worst air quality in the world
collinwood are the only fuels available
to heat the yurts and sometimes see he
can't even afford them
I helped her carry the colon brought
back home
you after David came back from
Afghanistan he was diagnosed with PTSD
post-traumatic stress disorder his life
fell apart my ex-wife for divorce
happened because it purely because what
my anger issues and I didn't really
think I had a problem so it was only
when I like to spend a year on my own
heavily drinking and no sleeping polish
drunk I was happy it's a horrible
pattern and then it just goes downhill
from there this is where I live my
little room oh boy spacious be i'll show
you my legs this is val here is my
cartoon leg is to one I use for like
walking long distance and over Hills and
uneven ground first quite heavy of all
of the European countries Britain had
largest military presence in Afghanistan
around 150,000 British soldiers served
there most of them younger than I am
over the past years they have been more
and more reported cases of British
soldiers with mental disorders the last
official count was over 5,300 that's a
seventy percent rise of a previous years
but those adjusts the official figures
I'm on my way to meet a man who says the
real numbers are much higher it is
estimated that one and five veterans
suffer from some form of mental disorder
some experts say the military isn't
doing enough to help them Oh welcome
hello you must be constantly well done
finding it Tony used to be a carnal then
he became a therapist he found at the
charity PTSD resolution in order to help
veterans for you to choose if you take
it scientifically there's only two
percent of the people have got a
diagnosis of PTSD but there's another 10
15
the depression another fifteen percent
with alka we say as therapists we say
that that's all part of the same problem
and that may be what the government
wants to do to minimize the problem so
they have less liability to do you think
this problem is underestimated yes five
years it's the difference it's getting
smaller leaving the house requires
careful preparation this is just one of
the many precautions Alex's had to
incorporate into his daily life if
anything happens to his heart device if
water or dust gets inside the battery
pack his life could be in serious danger
like many people in the area Alex works
on a vineyard but only part time and
only when the weather allows it all it
would take is just one slip in the mud
one bad fall and the Machine keeping him
alive could stop working even on a good
day he can only handle a few hours on
the job so no target in here shut up on
me today apply that and look taller I've
naxos the picture that my name is as
real as possible didn't it is equal to
bias rockmaster is love Oh masters
fighter just life Picabo feet flights
cosmos basically a godiva con are
obviously under co-edit on moc mat so
I'm life a medium gonzo sukhiya scans
emulsification alex is one of 11,000
people in Germany waiting for an organ
transplant
but the number of people donating their
organs is much lower in recent years
it's even gone down that's even though
seventy percent of Germans say they
support organ donation in theory
it's your momentum as Louis canning it
Duncan when I told Marvin on mr. might
indeed be multi oka underdone Thank this
with the hope concern for quotes my
illumise in the median does only value
making cleaning was nice all relief
medicine guns in the soccer pushed on
the meaty filling organic almonds of us
when this fingers with us I select and
ave A&B no me hacen excuse our country
Leonie other vendors / applause and
Jordan finished a few cantera
understanding my non grata was a burden
and kept me I'm of no nice time at the
Nelson and I Gazette's becoming an organ
donor in Germany is easy all you have to
do is get one of these in organ donors
card they're available lots of places
including pharmacies if more people had
these cards it would save lives three
people died in Germany everyday waiting
for a transplant
to keep warm Ziggy shares a bed with a
younger brother Mooji her doctor told
her if she gets sick again she could do
more damage to her lungs it's estimated
that in the next 20 years lung diseases
including chronic bronchitis we become
the world's third leading cause of death
before taking can light a new fire in
her yard she has to empty the ashes from
her stove and heck no cold outside it's
19 degrees below zero Celsius it's a
vicious circle in order to stay healthy
say he has to keep warm but that means
going out into the cold and burning more
wood and coal weird la Rionda yoga
without a heart akira atanas Horton I
was indifferent authority with a war
that ended in union skin boo-boos new
Tuscan person of Tarth Tarth now but
yeah Tim episod to Egyptian teacher was
in what order to go beyond the word Tim
Watson virus it will
scientists from Mongolia and Canada have
been examining the effects of air
pollution on the people here a study
they published showed that smog was
responsible for one in ten deaths in the
Mongolian capital now researchers
believe it may be as high as 1 in 4 smog
really is killing the people of Ulan
Bator
still there's little public awareness of
just how dangerous air pollution is to
the population
and I thought after leaving the military
David saw a therapist now he sleeps
better and he's not drinking as much but
as trauma will never go away in Charlie
David's ex-wife takes care of their son
David only sees him every other weekend
too he's still looking for work but for
now he can live off his pension from the
Army that's a day I woke up and he took
my leg off what do you think of your
decision now I'd go again yeah I won't
change anything I do it again I'd go
again I never what you really wanted to
leave the army why friends once it is
hard to explain because people don't
understand but it's to be of my friends
again where's your queen and country
when you're over there they're not there
are they so you find for your friends so
make sure you get to come home okay but
unfortunately you know everyone gets to
come home the way they went or come back
at all these can be quite so I sad about
David came back from battle different
than he was before the memories of war
will stay with him forever but for now
he's found a way to cope
Oh
you
in a tiny town like this one the
Volunteer Fire Department is the
backbone of many people's social lives
Alex had trained to rescue people if a
building was on fire he would have been
one of the first inside now he's had to
take a back seat but he tries to help
out by coordinating information for the
fire crew
Thanks on mimosa vendetta kool aid
agencies who hard for me to the other
devices are damasus I never
this may be just a drill but with all
the action I start to wonder how safe it
is for Alex and his heart support system
easy for estava life of the needles out
harder I thought I target leaky stalder
weakness before her Oh upload fine bring
for our system I'm so sorry for me hun
for indica league is ready [ __ ] I nope
still no it's it's always a favor
Pope Francis ticket
alex has no idea how much longer he'll
have to wait to get a new heart but
clearly he's determined to stay alive
for now it's goodbye but I'll be
checking in on him again soon segi is
also determined not to let her condition
get her down every weekend she goes
hiking with friends on the holy mountain
bak to him she says the fresh air here
will help her heal nor sure how touching
but see he can't keep up with the others
alongside her studies siggy volunteers
with an NGO next spring they'll be
planting trees in Ulan Bator finally
take he makes it to the top hmm ha ha
kadosh you got a hitachi church is that
to dialysis down 17 dicks to time seven
Vic here in the inner Tasha da your
attitude are hundred motto or he should
have been looted and a cut all she
wanted was a dude aqua I also to assure
the horse on with the one on single
Horton good cut Yahoo question dearest
minimal retain acoustic washing my
daughter shot into erotic also to
profile I've such the remote border it's
getting darker and the temperature is
dropping time to head back to the smoggy
city
you